hello everyone and welcome back to the
uh Havana uh Tournament of 1965 it is
the fourth capablanca Memorial
Tournament We are continuing with uh
basically showing some games that Bobby
Fischer played there and this is a game
from round five we've seen a game from
round one and round two especially that
spectacular Victory against um former
world champion vaselism uh so do check
it out if you haven't seen that I even
have a playlist for this tournament uh
then games three and four ended in a
draw for Fisher and now he faces a very
strong Bulgarian Grandmaster Georgie
tringo uh who okay this uh game was
played in 1965 he became an
international master in 1962 and the
Grand Master already in 1963. so he's
been a grand master for some two years
at the time this game was played so he's
uh he's a very strong he knows his
theory well he played in five World
student Team Championships and he also
represented Bulgaria in 12 uh olympiads
there's also a very fun story
um about tringo from from a chest
Olympia that was played in 1972 uh the
Year Bobby Fischer was fighting for his
world Chase championship title against
Boris pasty I think of played against
none other than Victor korshnoy in the
uh 1972 chess Olympia in Scorpio and it
was a really weird moment where I
believe on move 41 they had sealed the
move uh as the games would be adjourned
and then you have to seal the move and
tomorrow when you continue the game of
course they check out which move you
played but here as I understand it there
was a different rule before you uh you
just wrote the movie wanted to play on
your score sheet but here there was a
special envelope where you have to sort
of envelope the move in order you know
for the other Arbiter to take it out to
the the other day the next day and then
he would see what move you wanted to
play and then you would play it but a
girl he did not want to do that it's not
that he didn't know he just refused to
do that he did it the way he always did
it he just wrote the move on his score
sheet and ended the next day when he
showed up it cost him the game and you
know they did appeal for it but you know
the Arbiter said I mean rules are the
rules uh your game will be forfeited so
uh tough luck for him but you know if
the Arbiter tells you something just do
it during a chess game there's no really
any point in arguing there uh so that
being said let's check it out a girly
has the white pieces and he opens with
Pawn to E4 of course you guys all know
what Fisher replies to pawn to E4 he
plays the Sicilian Defense Pawn to C5
Knight to F3 D6 and now Pawn to D4 we
have characters captures Knight to F6
Knight to C3 and now Ponte A6 and
neither of Sicilian by Bobby Fischer
himself uh truly does not get any better
than this and here we have Bishop to G5
the top move even by today's standards
uh Ponte E6 and now Ponte F4 so as if it
were played in 2023 and Fisher of course
goes for Queen to B6 the poison Pawn
variation going after the B2 Pawn which
is well sometimes it's said to be
poisoned and it's it's a really weird
word I I think I already discussed this
once but if the pawn was poisoned
wouldn't it just die off you know if you
just left it alone for some time
wouldn't it just die off of poison uh
wouldn't a better word for the pawn be
poisonous Pawn because okay if it's
poisoned you ingest it you you die of
poisoning and if you leave it alone it
still dies as it's poison but if it's
merely poisonous then it can remain
there for as long as the pawn wants but
only if you take it uh because okay in
English you dictate you say take capture
for example in Croatian you will say you
eat the pawn so it makes a bit more
sense but yeah I always thought that it
would be more appropriate for it to be a
poisonous spawn rather than a poisoned
Pawn I could be wrong I I it just sounds
weird to me but okay uh the poison Pawn
variation Queen to B6 and now Queen to
D2 of course offering the poison pawn
and Fisher gladly accepts it Queen
captures on B2 Rook to B1 and now Queen
to A3 and and here we have Pawn to E5
now today Ponte F5 is the most popular
then Pawn to E5 then Bishop captures and
F6 those are the three lines that are
played uh in this poison Pawn variation
Fischer opts for Pawn to E5 and now we
have D captures on E5 F characters and
Fisher just goes Knight F to D7 and now
uh we have Bishop to C4 now this is a
fine move but it was last seen uh in
2007 okay there are some games where
white won some games uh Alexis defeated
one how with it also a Java defeated
karyakan with this bishop to C4 move uh
stealthagon uh tries to beat Anand with
it but it didn't work out and undefeated
him but it's not considered the best
nowadays uh here Knight the E4 is
considered best then there are some very
nice games
um that were played here uh sorry those
games that I've mentioned the followed
with Knight to E4 as they are modern
games of course not Bishop to C4 but
here we have Bishop to C4 and like I
said this uh move was last seen played
in 2007 so not considered anything
special you you can still like use it if
you play the poison Pawn against someone
maybe in a blitz or in a bullet game
maybe you can use it win some quick
games but other than that Knight the E4
should be played which is something that
fisher knew even in those days uh but
okay Bishop to be four by Fisher
absolute strongest move of course you go
after the Knight here but easily paired
Rook to B3 traces away the queen and now
Queen to A5 if you think okay this might
be a good idea to trade off uh Queens
here not really because here Rook
captures and C3 is played and now your
queen is still hanging and doesn't
really matter where you put the queen
now you don't really have good squares
here of course you're not going to put
it fade you might play uh let's say
queen B2 now Bishop captures on E6 and
you have problems here of course you you
cannot capture the bishop uh if you take
then just The Rook cap present C8 and
you uh get destroyed the the bishop
Discovery uh was a very uh very strong
uh so after Bishop captures you'll have
to play something like castles and then
after castles let's say just castles and
again not much to do here for black a
point being that if the bishop is
captured you simply play Rook captures
Knight captures and now of course Rook
captures and C8 and there's no way for
black to develop everything is
completely broken here like if Queen B1
check you can even play King F2 you
don't really care about your king being
and F2 here black is without a move here
if some like Queen to B6 okay now the
Knight cannot move uh Queen to F4 and
now if let's say queen to B4 guarding
the Knight here again doesn't matter
Knight captures an E6 opens up a
discovery and the queen also attacks the
Knight three times and even if you trade
Queen's captures cap doctors you don't
have a way of of playing this and even
if yeah Bishop captures even better then
next move of course you can capture or
if Knight a D7 then The Rook Falls so
you cannot play this so of course Fisher
knows this he plays Queen the A5 doesn't
touch the Knight and now both players
Castle to safety we have castles castles
and now the way to continue this is uh
not something you'd think of at first
the actual way to continue this is Queen
to F2 which looks stupid uh well I have
to say it as it does look stupid uh
because you've hung a knight on C3 but
the Knight cannot be captured and
because the Knight cannot be captured
you see how strong this move is and then
you will be able to move the Knight to
E4 and of course now you see that the
attacking formation is very strong then
the rule can be shifted over to the
attack then it comes to the E4 just
looking beautiful here but the point is
why you can't capture on C3 is the now
Knight captures on E6 is just brilliant
and there's a really no good reply here
Bishop T1 is the only good reply here
again if you don't know this chances are
you will not find it but point is after
I have characters and Bishop characters
you just get to checkmated okay you have
to give him the queen but it's not
really a problem Knight captures real
captors and you just get checkmated so
after this castles move uh here in an
official's opponent Georgie played
Knight captures on E6 and okay it's a
fine peace sacrifice you will get two
points you will get some sort of an
attack for it but you are it's Fisher
you are playing against so if you don't
make every move an engine move you are
not uh you know going through with this
attack so captures captures with check
King to h8 and now Rook captures an f8
now you cannot capture with the Knight
as the bishop here will fall as well so
Bishop has to go back now Black's pieces
are again a little bit passive and now
Queen to F4 and now uh uh what what can
you do here uh Fisher's position is
completely winning but you have to be
very very careful of course you can see
that uh
uh even the Knight well it doesn't get
developed well then Bishop captures and
C6 will remove the defender of the
bishop on f8 so how do you play this
what's the only move that fisher has
here that brings him Advantage feel free
to pause the video and win the game for
Fisher while I give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding this uh
well uh
wonderful developing move and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course Knight the C6 so this is
what Fisher played and now even though
you can capture it doesn't really matter
because then The Rook defends the bishop
and after this Knight the C6 move okay
Queen F6 queen queen F7 was attempted uh
and now just Queen to C5 with check this
um not only delivers check but also
guards the bishop on f8 so again you
don't have to worry about anything uh
weird here and also the thread of
Checkmate while is very nice it won't
really do all that much King to H1 was
played and now just Knight to F6
guarding against Checkmate and G8 so
here Bishop captures and C8 we have uh
Knight captures on E5 first and actually
sufficient two going after the White
Queen Queen to E6 and now Knight eat the
G4 and he was in this position on move
22 that Grand Master yorgi tening of
resigned the game as there is no nothing
more to be done here too much stuff is
hanging here the bishop here is King a
hanging and if you try to stop that with
some like Bishop captures on B7 or even
try to prevent some sort of a Checkmate
by by bringing the Rook all the way to
B1 uh it doesn't really matter it all
comes down to the same thing you are uh
within a smothered mate so now you have
to check in G1 is three checking each
one and even if Queen to G1 check you
pick up the queen Knight to F2 will be
Checkmate so this is I mean one of the
lines but pretty much whatever you play
that ends really really badly for uh for
Gorge
another very nice gameplay by Fisher
like I said this is a game from round
five so for now three wins two draws
we'll see what happens in the rest of
the tournament and while I might not
show all the games I will show the more
interesting ones and here you've seen
just how how strong Bobby Fisher was
back then how how much he knew Theory
how he knew here after uh of course this
Knight captures on E6 move was played
that it it wasn't uh gonna work and even
that okay Bishop to C4 not the absolute
best move uh like I said last time
played in 2007. so uh you know not uh
you know not the best and of course
Fisher knew this if you don't continue
with absolute best moves you will uh get
a worse position and then of course you
will have to sacrifice the piece in
order to justify your maybe worst
position and maybe try and win uh with a
little bit of luck but against Fisher
not today uh so yeah once again really
hope you guys enjoyed this uh from the
Kappa Blanca Memorial Tournament of
1965. uh I would like to thank James
Eugene Cashman and Brad Roth a bullet
just thriller.com uh John malpas and
Phil malthos for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day